the infamous team yellow drama continues
in fall guys
a new prince of persia listing was
spotted and vampire the masquerade
bloodlines 2
has let go of its lead writer i'm persia
and you reach your save state for
wednesday august 19th
team yellow has been at the heart of
some fall guys drama recently with
players claiming that they always lose
team games when on team yellow but
according to some stats released by
developer media tonic team yellow wins
just as much as anyone else
however some players are still skeptical
and others have even gone as far as
admitting
they sabotage their squad if they end up
on team yellow
mediatonic even released a tweet showing
that it would be willing to toss team
yellow
to the winds in exchange for a million
retweets well that didn't happen but the
fall guys twitter account did reach 1
million followers which then revealed
that
we are all team yellow now needless to
say i don't think there was ever a real
chance
at team yellow getting the axe but it's
worth noting that the screenshot said
team yellow is actually team number one
so maybe we've had it wrong the whole
time
it's been a little rough out there for
prince of persia fans with no releases
in the franchise for a decade now but
that might change
soon online listings for a mysterious
prince of persia remake appeared on a
guatemalan retail site and the internet
was quick to notice
the listings have since been removed
from the website but users on twitter
were quick to screenshot and speculate
on what it could be with the little
details provided the listing was for a
november 2020 release on ps4
and the nintendo switch but with the
title so vague
it's hard to tell if this will be for
the mid-2000s trilogy
the 2008 game or something else entirely
fans are already hoping for a full
trilogy but no official announcements
have been made
but ubisoft is planning a second ubisoft
forward stream
so there is a chance that we could hear
some official news soon
the lead writer on the original vampire
the masquerade bloodlines game will no
longer be involved in work on the sequel
ryan midsota has been suddenly
terminated from his position on the game
and he says it was a total surprise
speaking to rock paper shotgun mitsoda
said he was not
a part of any conversations that led to
the game's delay
and had never been led to believe that
he hadn't succeeded in delivering a
successor
to bloodlines publisher paradox
confirmed on its website
that minnesota and creative director kai
clooney were no longer employed at
heartsuit labs the studio handling
development on bloodlines too
even paradox interactive said the
contributions of brian and ka'i
were instrumental in establishing the
game's storyline so
how do you think their absence from the
project could affect the sequel
thanks so much for joining us today and
keep in mind that our play for all
donation drive is still open until the
end of august
you still have some time to get some
cool merch and help donate to black
lives matter
and coven 19 relief efforts we've made
it to wednesday so let's keep it up
feel free to give me a follow on twitter
at persia underscore xo and make sure
you come back and reach your safe state
tomorrow here on gamespot
see you later
you